taiwan's defense Ministry has reported
nine Chinese warships and 58 aircraft
around the island on Sunday Chinese
State media say the military is
protecting practicing rather an
encirclement of the island during the
second day of drills the operation was
announced in response to Taiwanese
president XI in wen's visit to the U.S
Victoria getting B hasmore
Taiwanese Coast Guard vessel issues all
use onto a Chinese warship taking part
in drills in the Taiwan Strait
you are now seriously damaging Regional
peace stability and safety please turn
around immediately and leave
on Saturday the defense Ministry
reported that 70 Chinese Jets crossed
the median line of the Taiwan Strait The
Unofficial barrier between the two sides
Beijing says the military is rehearsing
an encirclement of the self-governing
island which it sees as a breakaway
province the three-day exercise follows
Taiwanese president's cying wen's visit
to the U.S
in the capital Taipei people go about
their daily lives many say they
fluctuate between fear and indifference
the president traveling to different
countries has the effect of increasing
International awareness of Taiwan of
course verbal and Military intimidation
from China can't be avoided but I think
because this intimidation has been going
on for such a long time it's impossible
to ignore
China considers Taiwan part of its
territory and has not ruled out using
Force to take it but Taiwanese consider
themselves independent and reject the
one country two systems policy
to constantly talk about unification is
quite unnecessary or rather there is no
absolute need for this also China is
talking about unification while
threatening military action which is
quite pointless I think it's more
important for us to live our lives as we
are currently and have Taiwan achieve a
bigger position on the international
stage
the military
drip air traffic in a region crucial to
global trade more worrying perhaps
Beijing is turning up the heat on
another simmering conflict
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
well let's speak to Vincent Chao in
Taipei about this he's a former foreign
policy aide to present Tsai ingwen and
is now a Taipei City councilor thank you
very much Vincent for joining us on Al
Jazeera so we have China simulating
striking Taiwan on a second day of
drills now interestingly as we saw in
our report taiwan's residents seem
unfazed by these latest Maneuvers why is
that why are people seemingly not as
concerned in Taiwan
well thank you for having me and the
truth of the matter is that the people
of Taiwan have bravely faced this sort
of threat from China consistently over
the past two to three years now we've
seen consistent military action across
the Taiwan Strait we've seen for example
the Chinese engage in Naval and Air
Force drills in taiwan's vicinity we've
seen economic actions and sanctions
against Taiwan and this has
unfortunately been part and parcel of
the Cross trade relationship under Xi
Jinping from China but these exercises
are simulating strike in Taiwan I mean
how do they compare to China's response
last year when the U.S House speaker
Nancy Pelosi visited Taiwan
I would argue that last year we saw a
bit of um an increased escalation from
what the Chinese have done in the past
uh I don't think we've seen this over
the past two years I mean certainly the
Chinese have
um never made their intentions more
clear which is that
um they have never renounced the use of
force against Taiwan and exercises
pretending to strike Taiwan or to storm
taiwan's government offices this is
we've seen this in the past as well so I
do think that the Chinese are being a
bit more restrained this time around but
it's also for their own self-interest in
a sense that we do have a presidential
election coming up and the Chinese would
be mindful that any hard-headed approach
on this issue convertible backfire in
terms of their political interests here
in Taiwan I was going to ask you about
the the presidential election in 2024
what does the future hold for Taiwan
what impact is China's assertiveness
increasing assertiveness over Taiwan
going to have on the boat on the vote
and
Independence ambitions
so I think for president Tsai uh
although she's term limited and will not
participate in the 24 election she's
always been very clear-headed in terms
of what Taiwan needs uh Taiwan needs a
robust defense so she's committed to
that she's increased the defense budget
by Third over her term she's
reintroduced conscription she's
re-envisioned our military strategy to a
more asymmetric
um style and so that's part of it but
the second part of it is precisely what
she was doing in across the United
States in recent days which is just
broaden Town's International Space China
for a very long time has seen conflict
as part of this internal conflict
between the Chinese Communist party and
previously the gomindang of Taiwan and
so certainly I think it is in taiwan's
interest in president's highest interest
internationalize this issue and
hopefully to have other democracies step
in and and have a stake in enforcing
people you talk about stability here you
talk about internationalizing the issue
but at the same time we've seen Taiwan
lose a number of diplomatic allies nine
in fact since cying way became president
so wouldn't you
see it perhaps also that Taiwan is
increasingly becoming isolated on the
international stage
I would argue opposite I mean we have
had a number of diplomatic allies in the
past that are smaller countries around
the world in the Pacific Caribbean that
have continuously advocated for Taiwan
International I think that's important
but you know what's very important and
what's more essential for Taiwan
security are relations with the United
States with Europe with Japan with
Australia and other potential Democratic
Partners around the world and so these
are the issues that are going to keep
peace and stability here you know not
the number of diplomatic allies Taiwan
has Vincent ciao thank you very much for
talking to us
thank you